ja auf dem pixum whatsapp account da
habe ich zahlreiche nachrichten bekommen
die sich dieses thema gewünscht haben
hier ist es also es ist möglich mit dem
klonen der so ziemlich menschen
ähnlichen spezies dem affen in china
steht jetzt dem klonen von menschen
nichts mehr im wege und die konsequenzen
sind unglaublich und erschrecken wie sie
aussehen und was das für die zukunft der
menschheit bedeutet jetzt sind klicks um
science-fiction herzlich willkommen
im letzten tagen haben wir auf whatsapp
über sehr viele dinge diskutiert und
gechattet und ich habe darauf bin ich
ein wenig stolz wirklich jede nachricht
persönlich beantwortet die leute mit
denen ich dort schreibe die können hier
mal kommentieren um wie viel uhr sieben
zum teil meine antworten zu bekommen
haben im moment habe ich so noch 350 die
ich noch beantworten muss die usa sind
so ein bisschen meiner redaktion
geworden deshalb habe ich das jetzt
ausgebaut und man kann auch wirklich
redaktionsmitglied werden und im skype
konferenz und dem wirklichen
redaktionskonferenz mit über die themen
bestimmen
das wird haben wir das ganze wird über
beiträge ab taschengeldniveau auf patent
möglich habe sicher inzwischen rund 50
wirklich klasse themenvorschläge dort
bekommen vielen dank an dieser stelle
schon mal den mitgliedern
ja und das thema mit den geklonten affen
das wurde dort immer wieder
vorgeschlagen und heiß diskutiert denn
die konsequenzen sind wirklich
unfasslich 22 jahre nach dem klonen des
schafes dolly in großbritannien ist das
wirklich sensationelle gelungen zum
ersten mal wurde eine spezies geklont
die unserer so nah ist die von affen
genauer handelt es sich um langen
schwanz makaken dieser affenart lebt in
freier wildbahn in südostasien wird auf
der ganzen welt bei tierversuchen
eingesetzt um die beiden gekrönten
äffchen zu erzeugen mussten mehrere
hundert clown versuche unternommen
werden bis es endlich gelang
welche bedeutung dem versuch in china
beigemessen wird das sagen die namen der
beiden f king kong dong
ich hoffe ich habe es richtig
ausgebrochen und hua john hui heißt
china
man ist mächtig stolz auf dieses
gelungene experiment im reich der mitte
und in letzter zeit kommen immer mehr
wissenschaftliche erfolgsmeldungen von
dort denn die chinesische regierung
steckt inzwischen wie der westen
milliarden in die forschung nur ist man
dort skrupelloser so scheint es
jedenfalls wir haben ja hier gerade erst
über das frankenstein experiment
berichtet bei dem eine ratten menschen
schimäre erschaffen wurde ein wirklich
obskures mischwesen in china scheint
mehr möglich zu sein warum also nicht
menschen kloten wenn man sich das mal
durch denkt ist es einfach gruselig ich
könnte für ewige zeiten klickst du
moderieren wenn ich sterbe moderiert es
einfach ich also mein geklontes ich
weiter
es wird wahrscheinlich exakt genauso
viel leidenschaft für wissenschaft haben
wie ich wir würden immer wieder uns
selbst als kinder kriegen und selbst
können wir ja viel leichter vielleicht
erziehen es wird ja wie in star wars
clone armeen geben mit den besten geben
für soldaten ausgestattete superkämpfer
immer und immer wieder geklont
herausragenden künstler kämen immer
wieder auf die welt mozart beethoven
bach oder heute justin bieber michael
jackson madonna oder sportler becker
messi ronaldo
man könnte einen fußballverein der
superlative aufbau die chinesen wollen
da ja gerade durchstarten klonen würde
da einiges vereinfachen es ist verrückt
und beängstigend zugleich zwar betont
der leitende wissenschaftler von der
chinesischen akademie der wissenschaften
zitat und theoretisch gilt wenn wir
affen klonen können können wir auch
menschen lohn dafür sehen wir allerdings
keine notwendigkeit auch ethische fragen
verbieten uns das ja aber manchmal ist
ein dementi die beste bestätigung bisher
hat sich in der wissenschaft leider
gezeigt was möglich ist wird auch
gemacht als die erste atombombe gezündet
wurde
da war man sich im vorfeld der forschung
nicht so sicher ob sie nicht einen
weltenbrand eine entzündung der
atmosphäre auslösen würde
bei der alles zerstört würde ihr habt
sicher das war nur geringe zweifel aber
hätte man sich geirrt der bis heute
keine menschheit mehr ich fürchte also
das vielleicht stand in den nächsten
zehn jahren geklonte menschen geboren
werden man darf nicht vergessen dass
gerade ein wettlauf zwischen der
westlichen welt und china beginnt und
der kann verheerende folgen haben wenn
er als erstes neues zum thema und zu
allen anderen themen erfahren wollt dann
meldet euch hierbei whatsapp an dann
erfahrt ihr deutlich vor allen anderen
vom neuesten video garantierte könnte
direkt in der redaktion vom krieg zum
mitmachen und themen vorschlagen oder
fragen zu videos stellen
der direkte draht zu mir einfach hier
draufklicken und hier geht zwar damit
dafür auch draufklicken frankensteins
erben forscher erschaffen mensch platte
mischwesen ansonsten bis dann bleibt
dran